well hello again our we're back with a
show that's clearly going to look a
little unusual as I'm sure you've seen
the corona virus has forced a number of
late night hosts to record shows from
their houses and we're no different as
my home is and this is true a blank
white void full of sad facts where else
did you think I lived now a lot has
happened in the last two weeks and I'll
start with arguably the least important
development the last time we spoke I
mentioned the work done by a very
informative
tick-tock hamster well I'm thrilled to
tell you it seems the hamster saw it a
hamster just genuinely offered more
useful public health advice in one at 12
second tick tock then the president has
in multiple addresses to the nation yes
yes yes yes the hamster knows who I am
it might show just how much the
isolation is getting to me that is
genuinely heartwarming to experience
even a connection like that right now
and by the way I'd love to say that I
would vote for that hamster for
president but given that their average
life expectancy is just three years I'm
really gonna have to wait to find out
who its VP pick is but Kovach 19
continues to rip around the globe on
Friday Boris Johnson who had bragged
early this month about shaking hands
with coronavirus patients tested
positive for corona virus meanwhile
India's Prime Minister has imposed a
nationwide lock down of its 1.3 billion
residents with some police punishing
those who disobey by hitting them with
sticks and making them do squats and in
Italy which continues to be hit
incredibly hard there's been a trend of
local leaders posting videos online
yelling at their citizens for
irresponsibly going outside and their
incredible
Mia Riva no no TTA qualcuno Bouree
Bouree Bouree la fiesta de la brea man
diamo Carabinieri molly mandy amo
choreography on water duty police is not
even Dottie Adelia to TiVo you recorded
a Nidoran dr. Corday's Picacho deep are
you cheering Evelyn gasps
and to say gabble mm okay cut so servo
chair malavika kappa doge a hoodoo
voodoo Juvenal let me make a pedo gay
key got some never never see copy like
you said in dog food now I know that
seems extreme but he is right
if your hair is bad don't panic just let
it be bad for a while
yes people may see it and yes it'll be
embarrassing but you will get through it
trust me trust me hey listen trust me as
for here in the United States the virus
continues to spread rapidly we now have
more confirmed coronavirus cases than
any country in the world number one
number one and the president has only
recently seemed to realize the gravity
of the situation as recently as a month
ago he was saying we have it very much
under control adding stock market
starting to look very good to me before
abruptly shifting gears to claim that he
felt it was a pandemic long before it
was called one and then just last week
making this grand declaration I'm a
wartime president this is a war there's
a war different kind of a war that we've
ever had yeah I guess it is different
isn't it it's like World War two only
the enemy is invisible or like the
Vietnam War only this time Trump is
actually taking part and yet incredibly
after briefly embracing the need for
everyone to engage in social distancing
to flatten the curve on Tuesday our
wartime president seemed to already be
considering giving up the fight and
encouraging everyone to go back to work
we're opening up this incredible country
because we have to do that I'd love to
have it open by Easter okay I would love
to have it open by Easter I will I will
tell you that right now I would love to
have that it's such an important day for
other reasons but I'll make it an
important day for this - okay sending us
all to the east is an important day for
other reasons the date he's setting is
just two weeks from now which is
objectively way too soon although if
you're going to pick a holiday to break
quarantine you could do a lot worse than
one honoring the time that Jesus was
supposed to say inside and didn't and
it's worth taking a moment to appreciate
just how irresponsible that attitude is
because we wasted so much time that we
could have spent preparing the virus is
now widespread and thanks to how we have
massively botched the rollout of testing
for the virus we still don't know
exactly how bad things are so strict
social distancing measures are our best
shot at slowing this outbreak
epidemiologists have said if it were
possible to wave a magic wand and make
all Americans freeze in place for 14
days while sitting six feet apart the
whole epidemic would sputter to a halt
now obviously that magic wand is
impossible but some people aren't even
doing anything close to that and if you
need proof of just how true that is
just listen to the understandably
exhaust Brayton governor of Kentucky we
have a positive case today from someone
who attended a corona virus party and
this is the part where either person
that tell everybody to be calm have to
remain calm myself well good luck with
that because you just used the phrase
corona virus party and his disgust at
that infuriating term was perfectly
expressed by his sign language
interpreter who really got across the
whole what the is wrong with you
people sentiment truly that gesture
speaks for America right now give that
woman immediately so we absolutely
should not be relaxing measures yet and
and Trump actually can't force states to
do that it's up to governor's some of
whom from both parties are taking this
very seriously unfortunately other
governors are not Ron de santis in
Florida is still resisting issuing a
statewide stay at home order and in
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
took things even further agreeing with
the president that the economic damage
of a lockdown is just too great to bear
I'm not living in fear of covet 19
what I'm living in fear of is what's
happening to this country and you know
Tucker no one reached out to me and said
as a senior citizen are you willing to
take a chance on your survival in
exchange for keeping the America that
all America loves for your children and
grandchildren and if that's the exchange
I'm all-in what are you talking about
first if you really want to die so the
US economy can boom we already have a
system in place for that and it's called
Black Friday have at it
second we know what's happened in other
countries like Iran and Spain that
didn't take social distancing seriously
they're now home to mass graves you can
see from space and ice skating rinks
being used as makeshift morgues and I'm
in no way minimizing the economic
suffering caused by the shutdown and we
should do everything we can to mitigate
it this week stimulus bill is probably
only the start of what is needed for
workers but the idea that people should
sacrifice themselves for the economy is
absurd and yet it actually gained
traction this week co-signed by a
variety of conservative pundits perhaps
not more enthusiastically than this guy
I contend there are millions of
Americans just like me that will look at
their children and their grandchildren's
future and they will say I am NOT going
to have them a slave to debt I am NOT
going to erase their future because I
was afraid to die I'm not afraid to die
I am afraid that our nation might die
and that dooms millions to poverty
illness starvation and a lack of hope
let's see if that will trend yeah let's
see if that will trend you're thirsty
but you get that the corona virus
is not the Hunger Games right you can't
volunteer yourself as tribute and what
you're doing is actually much dark
you are actively volunteering others
including people of all ages with health
conditions to die and even if these guys
are okay with letting the coronavirus
kill as many people as it feels like so
that the economies protected which again
really there are and I cannot believe I
have to say this significant drawbacks
to hundreds of thousands of people dying
hospitals would be completely
overwhelmed which means people suffering
from things that aren't the coronavirus
also wouldn't be able to get the
treatment that they need leading to even
more people dying which to put this in
the only terms that they seem to care
about also tanks the economy so relaxing
social distancing right now isn't just
trading one bad outcome for another it's
trading one bad outcome for both bad
outcomes
it's on your cake and choking
on it too look it's critically important
for America to be getting a clear
consistent message about the severity of
the threat that we're currently facing
that is the only way that we will be
able to manage this virus contain
casualties and get back to something
resembling normalcy and floaty and
Easter end date isn't the only troubling
decision the president has made right
now one of the major challenges facing
hospitals across the country is a
critical shortage of even basic personal
protective equipment like masks
respirators gloves and face shields
because they are running short to an
alarming extent there are people that
literally are wearing bandanas because
they have nothing better than that to
protect themselves I've seen people
using the plastic protector sheets for
their kids homework to put in as a is a
face mask I've seen people even wearing
ski goggles and Halloween costumes that
were masked to try and cover up parts of
their face holy that is terrifying
both for the medical workers who are
risking their lives to help patients but
also for the patients
imagine being hospitalized for
coronavirus and then seeing this walk
through the door I'd opt out yeah
I died but that's better than whatever
this freaky is and it's not just
masks hospitals also need equipment like
ventilators to help people breathe
without enough of them people will die
and yet as recently as Thursday Trump
was choosing to not so much address the
problem as try and minimize it what you
dismiss a request for ventilators from
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo I have a
feeling that a lot of the numbers that
are being said in some areas are just
bigger than they're going to be I don't
believe you need 40,000 or 30,000
ventilators you know you go into major
hospital sometimes they'll have two
ventilators and now all of a sudden
they're saying can we order 30,000
ventilators yeah that's the problem
hospitals don't have that many
ventilators and now there's a pandemic
Trump must be so confused by fire
departments you walk into most houses
they got some sinks maybe a few cups now
all of a sudden they're on fire and they
say they need hundreds of gallons of
water sprayed at them with hoses I just
don't buy it and the thing is medical
equipment shortages are a problem that
Trump actually could help solve as a
wartime president he has a major tool at
his disposal for defense production act
it enables the federal government to
compel companies to prioritize the
production of essential supplies people
have been banking him to use that
authority for weeks now but he only did
so for the first time on Friday to force
GM and only GM to make ventilators and
it's not like the DPA can magic them out
of nowhere it could still take months
for companies to make them that is why
it would have been nice if Trump and
invoked it months ago you know
when he saw it was a pandemic before
everyone else and there is still so much
more he could be doing with the DPA
because it also allows the federal
government to take charge of allocating
materials like protective equipment and
direct them to where they're most needed
and without that happening right now
states are competing against each other
in a free-for-all as New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo will tell you I'm competing
with other states I'm bidding up other
states on the prices because you have
manufacturers who sit there and camp
California offers them for dollars and
they say well California offered $4 I
offer for $5 another state calls in
and/or for $6 it's it's not the way to
do it no it isn't States obviously
shouldn't have to hope they can outbid
each other for boxes of life-saving
equipment while the nation watches this
is the government's response to a
pandemic not storage wars again
and again Trump has failed to give this
crisis the seriousness it requires and
make no mistake this is serious too
often people discuss this in bloodless
terms citing the eeriness of empty
streets or closed schools but while the
streets may be empty hospitals are
increasingly bursting at the seams and
the agony this virus causes is profound
I'm sure you've been reading the same
stories I have of the woman who's 44
year old husband died from this or the
parents have a 25 year old who was
placed in a medically induced coma and
the health care workers on the
frontlines know that this is just the
beginning today is kind of getting worse
and worse we had to get a refrigerated
truck to store the bodies of patients
who are dying we are right now
scrambling to try to get a few
additional ventilators I want people to
know that this is bad
people are dying we don't have the tools
that we need in the emergency department
and in the hospital to take care of them
and and it's really hard yeah and this
was always going to be hard but it
actually didn't need to be this hard and
that is why it's so profoundly
disheartening that we're being led
through this crisis by a man who may be
less equipped to deal with this
historical moment than anybody in
recorded his
three just watch what happened when one
reporter pressed him on whether his
Easter deadline was wise just so you
understand are you ready I think there
are certain people that would like it
not to open so quickly I think there are
certain people that would like it to do
financially poorly because they think
that would be very good as far as
defeating me at the polls and I don't
know if that's so but I do think it's so
that a lot of that there are people in
your profession that would like that to
happen Alfa sake no one is
thinking about you these guidelines did
not revolve around you for once
something has come along that is more
toxic and more threatening than this
president and somehow he's got
stage Envy and look I know this isn't
exactly the first time that I've
criticized Donald Trump but I can't tell
you how much I was rooting for him to do
this better handling a crisis well is
not inherently political take Ohio
Governor Mike DeWine I disagree with him
on basically everything but he's doing a
pretty good job so far
also if I'm honest I never really liked
Andrew Cuomo before this but I will
admit he's doing admirably well and I
can't wait to get to the other side of
this when I go back to being irritated
by him again
and I wish I could honestly say that
we're going to be fine
but I don't know that most of us will
but not all of us and the number who
won't is very much up in the air right
now what is clear is that a crisis of
this magnitude ends up revealing a lot
about who you are as a nation and not
all of what's being revealed is good
these viruses disposing some central
vulnerabilities in our medical system
our political system and our national
psyche hospitals that have spent years
trying to operate at maximum efficiency
and now watching that efficiency turning
to scarcity our decentralized government
which can be good when local leaders are
empowered to protect their communities
has
so led to States fighting each other for
resources and a patchwork quarantine
strategy that will almost certainly draw
out the agony of this crisis meanwhile
we've been forced to confront some of
the strangest darkest implications of
our national mindset in which market
worship threatens to become a
death cult but at the same time this
virus has exposed some reserves of real
strength in this country we've seen
extraordinary heroism kindness and
ingenuity from everyone in essential
lines of work from our grocery store
workers to those making deliveries and
especially our medical professionals who
deserve among other things a
parade whenever we're allowed to have
parades again and the least we can do
right now is help them right now what we
all choose to do outside of our
hospitals has a direct and significant
impact on what happens inside of them
the more strictly that we all follow
social distancing guidelines to the
maximum extent that we can the easier it
will be for our health care workers to
do their jobs it is the only way to
counteract an appalling federal response
that inspires a mixture of anger
bafflement and disgust perhaps best
summed up by my new favorite sign
language interpreter who said if I may
translate what the and now this
you